bien ahora me quiero encontrar la
diferencia de 7 entre 12 menos 6 entre
13 y para esto quiero que te des cuenta
que no tenemos un denominador común este
su denominador es 12 mientras que de
esta otra función su denominador es 13
por lo tanto no tenemos denominador
común ahora cuando queremos hacer una
diferencia de fracciones que no tienen
el mismo denominador a lo que hay que
acudir es a un denominador común y el
denominador común siempre va a ser el
mínimo común múltiplo entre estos dos
ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que el 12 y el 13 no tiene factores en
común además el 13 es el consecutivo de
12 por lo tanto no hay forma de que
encontremos factores en común entre 12 y
13 y por lo tanto de una manera muy
rápida podemos decir que el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 12 y 13 es 12 por 3
entonces vamos a ponerlo así
el mínimo común múltiplo de estos dos es
por 3 ahora fijémonos primero en esta
fracción que tengo aquí 7 sobre 12 7
sobre 12 es una fracción que tiene como
denominador al 12 pero ahora en nuestro
denominador común es 12 por 13 entonces
lo que estoy haciendo en la parte de
abajo es tomarme el 12 13 veces y
recuerda que si yo quiero que la
refracción se mantenga igual lo que haga
arriba lo tengo que hacer abajo lo que
haga en el numerador lo tengo que hacer
en el denominador y viceversa en este
caso multiplique por 13 el denominador
así que vamos a multiplicar el numerador
también por 13 7 por 3 perfecto ahora a
esto le quiero quitar a 6 entre 3 sep
pero recuerdan que lo que necesitamos es
un denominador común que habíamos dicho
que el denominador común es la
multiplicación de 12 por 13 por lo tanto
me voy a tomar acá abajo 2 deportes de
ese 12 por 13 y ahora date cuenta que a
este 13 que tengo aquí abajo en mi
denominador me lo estoy tomando 12 veces
aplicando por 12 por lo tanto lo que
tengo que hacer es multiplicar la parte
de arriba también por 12 en este caso
ten cuidado ni denominador es 13 y lo
que hice fue multiplicarlo 12 veces y
por lo tanto voy a multiplicar la parte
de arriba el numerador también por 12 y
que me va a quedar 6 por 2 y en este
momento es cuando ponemos una carita
feliz porque ya tenemos un denominador
común nuestro denominador común es 12
por 13 y seguramente en este momento te
estás preguntando por qué no evaluamos
de expresión y estoy de acuerdo contigo
vamos a hacerlo cuánto es 12 por 13 que
es mi denominador común vamos a
calcularlo aquí 12 por 13 cuántos esto 3
por 2 6 y no llevamos nada 3 por 13 y
después aquí pongo un 0 y bajo este 12
porque 1 por 12 es 12 y me va a dar
325 y este uno baja 156 mil denominador
común y mínimo común múltiplo es 156 156
perfecto y después aquí dice 7 por 13
cuando será eso 13 13 por 7 es mucho más
fácil tomarme esto 7 por 3 21 llevamos
27 por 17 y 29 91 entonces me quedan 91
en 356 esta es mi es cuestión de volado
que por cierto de 7 12 a vos ya ha visto
en términos de mi denominador común ya
esto le voy a quitar le voy a quitar
esta expresión de aquí esta expresión de
aquí que por cierto la parte de abajo ya
sé cuánto vale 12 por 13 12 por 13 es
156 156 y después tengo que evaluar 6
por 12 4 cesó
veamos 12
66 por 2 12 llevamos 16 por 16 y 17 72
entonces a 91 en 356 le voy a quitar 72
el 356 y está de lujo porque ya tenemos
aquí un denominador común ya puedo decir
que esto es exactamente lo mismo y aquí
voy a poner 156 que es mi denominador
común y arriba tengo 91 ya esto le tengo
que quitar 72 ya esto tengo que quedar
72 que por cierto cuánto es esto pues
vamos a ver a 91 menos 72
esto me da 1919 entre 156 a ver veamos
72 más 10 es 82 más 9 el 91 perfecto 19
en 356 y bueno si tú lo que te estás
preguntando es si esta fracción la
podemos simplificar
y creo que la respuesta es que no porque
fíjate bien 19 es un número primo eso lo
sabemos muy bien por lo tanto los
factores de 19 o es uno o es 19 156
salió de 12 por 13 por lo tanto ni 12 y
13 tiene como factores al 19 pero de
todas maneras si tú tienes la duda
podemos verificar lo 156 lo voy a
dividir entre 19 y cuántos esto
esto es como 20 20 cuántas veces caben
en 156 cabe siete veces creo que si
alcanza ocho veces veamos
8 por 9 8 por 9 72 y llevamos 7 ok 8 por
18 y 7 son 15 perfecto si cupo y me voy
a tomar la resta ahí me sobran 4 por lo
tanto 19 no cabe de manera exacta en 156
entonces esta fracción no se puede
simplificar mi respuesta es 19 entre 156
y
salió de tomarme la diferencia de 7
entre 12 menos 6 entre 13 encontrando mi
denominador común ya está así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo